today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
[Music]
convalescent flows from strong
antibodies
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
convalescence of
operation convalescent today i'm pleased
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million to fund the mayo
clinic study that tested the
efficacy of
[Music]
convalescence
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman he
is a baby
david patman he is
david patman he is
pacman he is a pain
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but
whoa whoa jesse will we we gotta that's
a lot
that's a lot of people agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is a baby
david pacman he is
all right there's too much going on to
keep going with that silliness
uh welcome i'm glad you are joining me
we are
expecting um that somebody very very
soon
is going to be the first to say that
joseph r
biden jr has won the 2020 presidential
election and i want to make sure but we
have so much to discuss today
but before we get into it i don't want
anybody to he
be at all confused this race has been
called by decision desk hq
they are a completely legitimate
reasonable
and trusted source of election data
this race has been called for joseph r
biden jr with 273
electoral votes they have given uh
joseph r biden jr pennsylvania um
and uh that that is it with pennsylvania
nothing else matters they're not even
giving him arizona yet which fox news
and the associated press feel good about
they have not given him nevada so
the race has been called by decision
desk we've also called the race
does that mean anything no i'm just a
guy in a room with a light but
a couple lights but um there are
increasing questions about why networks
are not calling it and there's some
question as to
who wants to go first what sort of wrath
do they risk bringing upon themselves
uh if they are first to call it uh we
heard i believe it was from
nbc news that they want to see
pennsylvania get to a 35
000 vote margin before they call it it's
currently a 15 000 vote margin with 96
of the vote in we don't know if and when
we are going to get more data as far as
today goes we are
still looking at north carolina nothing
has come in there for several days now
we expect we won't have the north
carolina data until november 12th it's
going to be irrelevant
georgia has also flipped to joseph r
biden jr
it is the slimmest of slim margins
arizona remains on the side of joe biden
more votes came in from the las vegas
area
and again make the possible comeback of
donald trump
even less likely and then in nevada we
got our update earlier today
um and again now up to 92 percent of the
estimated vote reported
joe biden winning by 21 20 20 and a half
thousand votes
1.6 and again you start doing math what
would it take to reverse the results
first trump would have to pull even and
then ahead
and there really is not a path for that
pennsylvania alone secures the win for
joe biden
certainly with arizona and nevada it
gets even bigger and
with georgia in fact maybe i even have
it here
with nevada pennsylvania not north
carolina and georgia you're talking
about 306
electoral votes and that would be
a bigger win than donald trump had in
2016. so it is a matter of time
and we don't know who will be the first
network to
call it but the news is this has been
called by decision
desk hq for joe biden now with a
popular vote lead of uh
3.87
million votes 3.872 million votes and of
course
if this was popular vote trump would
have lost
already definitively and very very
clearly
if this were popular vote donald trump
wouldn't even be on the ballot
because hillary clinton easily won in
2016 but alas it is not now let me say
just one thing about that
for people who have been contacting me
and saying david
uh oh people say trump had 306. i had
thought that trump had 304
in 2016. did he have 306 oh trump
people are saying 306. oh i've been
having a 304
goal of website members and twitch subs
because i thought well let's make it
306. okay we've updated that thank you i
appreciate the
two faithless oh okay okay okay okay
yeah that's an important detail
so listen there's a lot of people saying
will joe biden eliminate the electoral
college he will not joe biden will not
do it because it's not up to joe biden
if people really want to understand what
i think is the most
plot plausible path to a national
popular vote go to
nationalpopularvote.com
the idea of the national popular vote
interstate
compact is as follows any
individual state can award their
electors however the hell they want
so for example the state of ohio could
say
we will give our 18 electors to whoever
wins the popular vote
in our state but the state of ohio could
say something different the state of
ohio could say
we will give our 18 electors
to whoever wins the national popular
vote
if enough states say we will give our
electors not to the winner of our state
but to the winner of the national
popular vote you have a
de facto national popular vote now as of
right now
this has been enacted in um
hold on let's see national popular vote
has been
okay as of july 2020 it has been enacted
into law in 16 jurisdictions possessing
196
electoral votes okay you need
an additional 74 electoral votes worth
of states to say
hey instead of giving our electors to
whoever wins
our state we will give them to whoever
wins
the popular vote and then without any
constitutional amendment
without any congressional action without
any of it you have a de facto
popular vote now there are states if you
look at the orange states
those have passed a national popular
vote
by one legislative chamber
meaning they are halfway there that
includes virginia north carolina maine
michigan minnesota arkansas
oklahoma arizona now i don't know if
that's enough
28 32 50 60 67
70 78 oh it actually it it would be
enough yeah
so in any case the point is if people
are interested
in the national popular vote go to
nationalpopularvote.com i think that
that
is the most likely path forward as we
continue to await an official call
but the big news today not only has
pennsylvania switched to
joe biden not only has georgia flipped
to joe biden
not only is arizona still joe biden
not only is nevada still joe biden
decision desk hq
has called the race they have called the
race for joe biden
i have called the race for joe biden now
i want to set expectations for people
there is a completely reasonable
possibility
that there continues to be some
uncertainty all the way up until
december 14th at which point
electors actually certify and say
we as electors for our respective states
vote for biden and trump there
are rumors that donald trump is not
planning to concede remember concession
is
it's irrelevant legally it's just a
formality but the point is
trump is planning to use lawyers and
continue fighting this on
and on and on so this may not end
fully until december 14th and then
you start to raise the question of what
about faithless electors
what if joe biden doesn't get any of
these other states
and gets exactly 270. if pennsylvania
goes trump
and georgia goes trump and oh
there you go and biden has 270.
what if two electors from i don't know
virginia vote for trump on december 14th
i'm not even going to get into that
right now but that is one of the
but oh yeah and as people are pointing
out faithless electors could go both
ways as well there's always the
possibility that there will be
trump electors from texas for example
where
it was very very tight until the very
end and still for texas it's quite tight
what if two texas electors go for biden
that could happen on both sides for sure
or they vote for kanye as people are
mentioning in the chat or whatever the
case may be
all possibilities all possibilities but
um this is essentially over in terms of
logic in terms of bogus legal challenges
it may continue
joe biden and kamala harris scheduled to
address the nation tonight
at uh wait where is that stream i had a
stream going there uh
here it is scheduled to address the
nation at eight pm eastern i don't plan
on streaming that long
i will not hear will will i will not be
here with you fine folks
in uh three hours but that is scheduled
for later today
all right so we've got a lot of things
to discuss here
um super chats are coming in very very
strongly
johnny minogue liked the statement from
the mayor of philadelphia
i actually have that i tried to have
i know people think like i just sit down
and start streaming random stuff i
actually do try to be prepared so i
tweeted this because i wanted to have it
ready
here's the mayor of philadelphia with an
admonishment
for donald j trump you know i think what
the president needs to do is
frankly put his big boy pants on he
needs to acknowledge the fact that he
lost
and he needs to congratulate the winner
just as jimmy carter did just as george
h.w bush did
and frankly just as al gore did and stop
this and let us move forward as a
country
and that's my feeling i doubt he'll
listen to me but
that's it beautiful message for mayor
jim kenney democrat of philadelphia it
really is time for trump to put on his
big boy pants and by the way
we are working on some really good
compilations
um producer pat
hold on a second this is uh
producer pat had this great idea
producer pat is going to be making a
compilation over the weekend
of donald trump and fox news complaining
about how hillary didn't accept the 2016
election so we've got a powerful
compilation coming for you guys by next
week
and producer pat also wants to do oh
hold on a second uh wait a second we've
got to do a ban hammer
sorry guys uh
people are getting really upset so we're
having to ban a lot of people
unfortunately
producer pat also is going to do a
compilation
of trump talking about people being
losers which he hates people losing like
a dog
as donald trump says all of that stuff
so we're gonna have that compilation for
you guys next week as well
the other compilation i think we should
do
is one of all the grifters i'm not i'm
not going to name anybody but all of the
grifters who over the last
few weeks have made youtube videos like
trump landslide impossible to stop
um the mistake joe biden made
which sealed an explosive inevitable
victory for donald trump
we're going to put all of those together
and i actually need you guys help with
that
uh you guys's or y'all's help i guess we
could say
with that and we are taking submissions
for that compilation
you can use the contact form at
davidpakman.com
for that as well okay uh
let's see who else let me just do a
couple bands over on youtube
wow i've already banned two people on
twitch and one on youtube
um moderators let's let's be on alert
because these are these are
sensitive times people asking whether i
put money on the election no
i don't i don't bet on stuff i mean
listen i bet on
the show doing well in our coverage
by planning to you know do wall-to-wall
coverage
daily streams that was the bet i made it
was a work bet
a very strong very strong work bet other
super chats coming in
um taylor says david you didn't talk
about trafalgar groups polling monday
they were the only ones who saw this
coming they were pretty spot on
yeah i don't know anything about
trafalgar group maybe next week i'll
have time to look at that but i just
don't know anything about it i just know
it's
sort of like a right right right leaning
pole
um jorgen asks says norwegian tv2 called
biden the winner this morning at nine
eastern mr president you're fired
okay yeah let me get to a couple of
other things as far as that goes
oh and before i go anywhere else
it's been a very stressful week for a
lot of people as you can see the trolls
are out in the chat
i want to give you guys just something
really really nice that
this is just great okay i think this is
just a little break
uh here is sumo
the boxer dog okay this is a dog
that was reported to me loves the show
is enraptured by my voice okay this is
just
a nice thing let's take a look at this
sumo
what a good dog just loves it take a
look because our governor is buddy buddy
with trump and they're ignoring
guidelines and opening everything and
having huge events so the virus spreads
and hurts the economy
yeah i do disapprove of that but vote
for joe biden no but
no way i'm voting for donald trump again
win or lose not 60 million
but 67 million trumpists who live in
this country
who will continue to live here no matter
who wins the presidential election
that is a dog that is locked in
on indep independent progressive
analysis
uh and rumor actually has it that i've
de-radicalized this dog this dog
actually fell down
the the right-wing youtube conspiracy
rabbit hole they were looking at ben
they were watching really horrible stuff
and thanks to me we have de-radicalized
sumo the female boxer dog
a huge win huge win in the battle of
ideas so anyway if your pets like the
show
get the videos and people definitely
definitely seem to like those
okay let's get into some of the material
that we have
um oh and sorry before i do that i
i i'm not ignoring any of these signups
let me let me get to them i want to say
thanks to miller adams for signing up at
joinedpakman.com
andy homunu is new member number two
ann marie parker has signed up at
joinpackman.com janice rozic is new
member number four
israel matthias is new member number
five edward roading number six
and zaza coke zaza coke
is new member number seven now by
popular demand
and to be more inclusive of people of
all stripes we are also
including twitch subs in our goals we
started at
2140 we are now at 2173
which is an additional um 33
putting us at 40 and for people who are
don't know what that what the hell is
this guy talking about
uh our primary source of funding is
website memberships we have a new code
because we're taking a fresh start with
joe biden
and hopefully taking a fresh start on
sanity our coupon code
fresh start will apply to any
uh membership at joinpakman.com it's 70
percent off
and a huge thank you to a chess
grandmaster benjamin feingold who just
subscribed
over on twitch and ben and i very very
soon
ben is going to try to raise my chest
skill level
my rating from 905 to 9 15
that's the goal we're going to be doing
something with ben very soon and ben i
have your
uh i have your email in my to respond to
folder but it's just been crazy with the
election so we're going to get all of
that going soon
alright guys let's get into some stuff
first of all
coronavirus is completely out of control
119 000 cases of the virus yesterday
99 000 cases of the virus today
joe biden immediately needs to start
a parallel or you might call it a shadow
coronavirus task force
i think it's complicated with fouchy
because he technically still is a
government employee i i don't know
i would love to see fouchy on it
starting tuesday or wherever
joe biden should just take take a lead
on on uh take a lead on this
joe biden should start calling governors
and saying governor let's do a mask
mandate uh i'm not coming in and
violating federalism
i'm just saying let's do a mass mandate
um have fouchy speaking to the nation
two three four times a week um we we
have to do it because this is swirling
completely out of control
as you can see here look at these
numbers these are just
disgusting numbers this is what trump
wishes his polling looked like
unfortunately it's coronavirus cases and
i think folks are saying that these
numbers today don't even include texas
is that true
uh where is texas no i think they do
oh i'm sorry it's at the top of the list
it is without even including texas
you're absolutely right
so what i would like to see from joe
biden is
of course start to put together a list
of executive orders that you will file
on day one
to start dealing with the trump fiascos
whatever you can undo by executive order
have the list ready
i think it would be a powerful signal if
on day one joe biden did that
but start a parallel shadow coronavirus
task force right away you got to do it
right away
so that's number one number two donald
trump
is completely losing it on twitter i've
been uh
doing a few clips covering the meltdown
where are the missing military ballots
in
georgia with the attack by the radical
left dems on the republican senate the
presidency becomes either more important
even more important
uh just on and on and on philadelphia
actually philadelphia has a
rotten history on election integrity
twitter is
out of control some of these have been
flagged
i easily win the presidency of the
united states with legal votes cast blah
blah blah blah blah
and what's going on now is let me find
where i have this tweet
um here it is here's what's going on now
trump has told people he has no
intention of conceding the election even
if his path to victory is effectively
blocked
trump world is becoming concerned that
someone is going to have
to reckon with him that his this race is
coming to an end
sources said there has been talk of
maybe leaving it to jared kushner or
ivanka
white house officials don't believe it
will come from someone like mark meadows
who in recent days has fed trump's claim
that the election is being stolen from
him understand what is likely going to
happen at the white house at some point
in the next few days
someone apparently jared kushner or
ivanka are going to be sent in like
sacrificial lambs
to say sir um
it's over you have no path
and for your own sake start behaving
like an adult i mean that's not what
they will say but they're going to have
to do it
and i don't envy whoever is ultimately
going to have to do that
but um it is it is something that is
going to have to be reckoned with
and i uh don't know who who it's
ultimately going to be
jl's asking if there's still a chance
the senate might go blue
i i think it's tough but it's not
impossible at this point
kyle says we need to discuss trump's
unprecedented attack on democracy
yesterday in his press conference
regardless of what party you come from
come from election
integrity is sacred period
yeah it was a delusional presentation
that donald trump made yesterday
completely delusional presentation if
you're just joining us i know people are
asking
has it been called yet i want people to
understand
decision desk hq has called it it's over
decision desk hq has called it for joe
biden with 273 electoral votes
it is unclear why no one else has called
it yet
there was the thought that fox news
wanted to be first
in order to maybe start greasing the
wheels to not be
completely shut out of government when
joe biden takes over
uh but they have not called it yet
nobody has yet called it
and nbc has said at least this morning
nbc said they will call pennsylvania
when the lead is 35 000.
it's about 15 000 right now so
you know the counting is so so slow
there
that we don't really know when when
that's going to be
um but uh the other possibility that
some are suggesting
is they're waiting for prime time
i don't know i don't know about that
okay a couple of other things that i
want to look at
donald trump jr is also it's it's
diarrhea of misinformation
that he is spreading um
retweeting things about ballot dumps
and glitches from who knows who these
people are
um oh katie pavlich is completely toxic
retweeting kaylee magananny who is
retweeting
mark levin all caps insanity
uh alum bakari talking about
facebook i mean it's like he doesn't
even know what to do
uh links to town hall
about you know who even knows back
dating ballot
i mean all understand all of this stuff
is completely
uh not based in reality don jr tweeting
about statistical impossibilities does
he have any
does he have as if he has any
understanding whatsoever about
statistics
um i mean it's just crazy stuff that
he's tweeting
some video from a guy named ian miles
cheong
uh it's it's just all day
all day jack pazzabiak another
conspiracy theorist
it's never ending it's never ending
stuff
uh he's retweeting dave rubin
dave rubin i heard dave dave rubin i
guess has gone in on the fraud
um story
uh more pobasiak we're tweeting james
o'keefe
uh who has has james o'keefe ever done a
non-debunked bombshell
every bombshell i remember from james
o'keefe has been debunked
retweeting charlie cork it's never
ending so that's
that's don jr that's that's been his
last uh a couple days
we did the caitlyn collins thing um oh
a couple other video clips so let me
you've got to see some of these videos
aaron rupar is all over this stuff
here is jonathan turley saying
that listen even if there's no evidence
of irregularities
if we start doing recounts maybe then
we'll find irregularities
what a completely indefeasible it's an
unfalsifiable claim okay take a look at
this
and i think that if the situation was
reversed we would have a demand for
recounts
the thing about recounts is they don't
move a lot of votes but there is one
difference this year
recounts can show irregularities
and since we this is a very irregular
election to begin with with so many male
1
remember it's irregular because trump
preemptively said he would only accept
the results if he wins that's the
irregularity
and voting it may highlight
common problems like the ones being
alleged in nevada
that come out of recounts understand
that when they say
if we start doing other things it's
conceivable
that alleged problems will will turn up
so what what you're saying
unproven that we may find more unproven
allegations similar to the unproven
allegations already made
come on guys come on um
okay fox news i guess uh
starting to say you know it wasn't quite
so good what donald trump did
said the other night when he claimed
victory and um each one of these states
especially georgia you have a republican
governor and a republican secretary of
state
they are coming out and briefing they
have not seen
widespread fraud as of yet if you're
finding things
they're probably going to look into it
because there's going to be a recount
but for the president to come
out the other night and say definitively
in that press conference
the democrats are stealing the election
that there is
fraud doesn't that hurt the system
overall even if he believes it so
understand
we are not now to praise fox news they
are still the complete and total you
know
trash central um but they are starting
to position themselves not to lose
access to the white house
and the president uh when when joe biden
is inaugurated that's what fox news is
now doing you have to understand their
main priority
is one of self-preservation um
here is republican uh
majority leader of the pennsylvania
state senate jake corman saying he's not
aware of any irregularities in
pennsylvania
and now you know the integrity of this
lecture is called into question i don't
have any evidence of any misdoing but
for all their actions is leading to
wondering why they didn't want people
watching this process
didn't allow pool watchers in the into
pre-voting yeah so he's not aware of any
problems
um what else do we have
uh oh hold on more from jonathan turley
because
at the end of the day donald trump is
the president united states
and he may have the greatest moment of
his career in bringing us together
even if it's not a concession speech
trump's going to unify the country any
moment that can you believe that
uh this was fox and friends this morning
then we'll get away from this despondent
fox new fox and friends completely
despondent here
and uh not not pleased by what we are
seeing
major major turn of events overnight so
that's that okay
let's look here this is rudy giuliani's
exclusive podcast episode released today
the theft of the century okay are you
guys ready for this let's take a look
it's rudy giuliani and i'm back with you
with rudy's common sense
this should be good an extraordinary uh
period of time
this election of course has been the
most unusual in american history
right now is going to be the most
unusual election count
in american history probably challenging
bush v gore
um let me tell you my experience i've
been here in
washington dc for a number of days seems
to have ink all over his left thumb you
guys see that
uh to deal first with the uh aftermath
the last couple days of the election
actually on both
that hangover
when i went to bed which was very very
late on
tuesday night wednesday morning i'd say
around three or four in the morning
i was quite confident that president
trump had won reelection
based on every well again so this is
this is something they do
they use in misguided prior beliefs
to justify continue listen
i was wrongly thinking trump won it on
tuesday night at 2 30 in the morning
when he announced it and clearly we now
have to base
everything on my incorrect assessment
from tuesday night
it's meaningless tyria that i i knew
from prior elections which go back to
really with any experience john
kennedy's and before that as a child i
remember eisenhower
in 52 so yeah
i'm not a baby and uh
he had won and i'm going to tell you how
how he had won and what they hadn't
called
they hadn't called pennsylvania for him
as of that time and it was only
so this is 20 minutes long let's just
skip ahead to see what else he's doing i
want to see if at any point he picks up
uh oh my god wait a second what is he oh
my god is he advertising cigars
hold on they cut to an ad here let me
look at this tell me they're not corrupt
tell me they're not corrupt this is a
good time to take a break
if you want a good cigar go to a good
cigar shop
you want the best go to famous smoke
shop
let famous smoke deliver your favorite
cigars
right to your doorstep at america's
lowest
prices famous opened in 1939 as a small
shop
in new york city oh my god today it's
the largest okay so he then he comes
back from advertising cigars
i guess to wrap up the fraud story
all for biden all for biden
you think those were cast by real voters
do you think they were cast by some
democrat
sitting in a back room
it's been there playing all along it is
totally
impossible illogical
irrational that the same thing would
happen in all
five or six places so there's rudy's
story and he's sticking to it guys so
that is that and then i have a couple of
other clips to play for you
let's see what is going on right now on
all of the major networks uh still no
call here
from um abc uh
still no call from nbc
and still no call from what is the cbs
from cbs news i was told to check out
what's happening on this is sky
news i've been told that their coverage
is particularly unhinged this is owned
by news corporation which also owns fox
news
let's just listen to a little bit of
this i want to see how they're covering
it
despite growing impatience from his
opponents
the long arduous slog of counting
continues and it seems to be favoring
joe biden
[Applause]
but mr trump's fans believe he's
stealing the election
looks like america's like british
[ __ ] divided
around its own democracy democrats have
already started to adopt the language of
victory
president-elect biden has a strong
mandate to lead
and will have a strong democratic house
with him
and many democrats in the senate this
has been a life or death fight for the
fate of our democracy as he says the
soul of our country
we did not win every battle in the house
but we did win the war
anyway um i see people saying sky news
is more impartial than fox news that may
be
at the same time at one point sky news
wasn't even allowed in many countries
which is uh which is pretty wild so
that's sky
news that is happening there as we
continue to wait for more
uh more more of the vote to be
counted okay let me get just a quick
update on
uh i know a lot of people are saying
david you missed my membership i did not
miss your membership
i definitely did not miss your
membership okay we were
at eight we're now at 30. so that puts
us at 22
above 40 is 62 and as far as twitch
we're at 21.86 which is an additional
13.75 perfect yeah so today
everything counts website memberships
count twitch subscount as well all right
let me see what else i had for you i had
so much stuff prepared
um this is david bossie a former trump
deputy campaign manager
telling a black guy that he's out of his
cotton-picking mind let's take a listen
to that
your final point all right you said that
about david david michael
michael hayden posted a picture of
auschwitz
he's talking about liberal michael
hayden yeah that's screaming
michael hayden you're out of your
cotton-picking mind cotton
let me tell you all right i got some i
got something all right i got some
relatives
this is this is really cool you guys
want me to like that
on tv you're out of your mind
this is what's going on in america this
is what we're about
all right thank you gentlemen this is a
civil note
okay yeah and this is actually old i
don't even know why why am i watching
this right now this is an old clip
i have no idea why this is here how did
this get sent to me as something new
this is an old clip
anyway very interesting clip but very
very old
anyway if you were wondering what
happened on fox news in 2018
it was that i have no clue how that even
made it into the
coverage for today i guess i'm fired oh
my god
i guess we're just reviewing a classic
okay yeah it's like a bunch of people
sent me that everybody
i didn't even check the date on it i
don't know how that got past me but
just uh so that was that happened on fox
completely unrelated to this election
other than it was somebody related to uh
the trump campaign at the time
so that's that um here
is oh oh oh oh you guys have to see this
you guys have to see that this is this
is wild
this is um pres this is trump's
spiritual advisor
she decided to take the approach of
i guess praying for victory this was
yesterday
this should be an emote this should be a
song if joe woodward is watching
take a listen to this strike and strike
and strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike until you have victory
for every enemy that is aligned against
you let there be
that we would strike the ground for you
will give us victory god
i hear a sound of abundance of rain i
hear a sound i like when a guy walks by
in the background
the sound of shouting and singing i hear
a sound of victory
i hear a sound of an abundance of rain i
hear a sound of victory
i hear a sound of an abundance of rain i
hear a sound of victory
right the lord this guy the funniest
thing is he's carrying his coat and
holding
he looks like he's at the insurance
salesman's convention and he's trying to
figure out which room is the panel on
universal whole life insurance cause it
is done
the lord says it is done for i hear
victory victory victory victory in the
quarters of heaven
in the quarters of heaven victory
victory victory
back he's like whoops actually i'm more
interested in annuities
for angels are being released right now
angels are being dispatched right now
i have to tell you hamanda akarata is
the most sensible thing she said in this
video
dispatch from africa right now africa
right now africa right now from africa
right now
they're coming here they're coming okay
anyway this continues divide every
demonic confederacy
against the election against america
against that who you have declared to be
in the white house
we break it up in the name of there's
this guy can somebody actually explain
to me
what is the guy in the background doing
like i know we're joe
like why is he walking by like that does
anybody unders i've never been to a
church like this
i really don't understand why he there
oh there he goes again
why is that guy there
he's next okay um and i guess this
insanity continued today as well
this was um this was this was another
one push back every agenda
that would that would release a
premature satanic agenda
in the name of jesus anything that would
that would be of an antichrist spirit
oh my god every detail is beyond satire
like there's a guy with a 45
jersey who's i guess praying we break it
right now
in the name of jesus every antichrist
spirit we break it right now
every antichrist agenda agenda
we break it we override it we overturn
it we overturn it we overturn it in the
name of jesus
right now god we just declare that you
will keep the
feet of potus in his purpose and his
position right now
right stop and we override the will of
man for the will of god
now what happens when trump finally is
deposed
if you sit down paula white and you say
paula listen you know
you did the prayer and trump didn't win
do you think that it's because god isn't
listening to you because you're bad or
did you not do the prayer correctly did
you not do enough prayer
was it a demonic thing did joe biden
have like the the power of satan
counteracting it like what would be the
explanation for when that insanity
doesn't work i'd be very very curious to
know
uh and i don't i don't know what it is
that that she would say
um okay let's see
here uh oh this is a genius idea this is
perfect
someone please photoshop the walking guy
in the background to be david
that's brilliant if if there's people
who are good
at you know elements of graphic design
if you can make it so that i'm the guy
walking behind her
i think that that would be absolutely
hilarious and extra points
if you are able to integrate one of joe
woodward's songs like plasma or
david pakman as a beta male or something
like that
um yeah let's let's do it that would be
absolutely fantastic i would love to see
that
okay i do want to hear from people i
know i've been missing a whole bunch of
different
stuff here and i i'm really really sorry
about that it's just like impossible to
keep up
let me see if i have any twitch messages
that have come in
carol lang's staff says so happy to have
this forum to keep it real and honest
kudos to you david
musky manatees says thanks for the
sanity
thank you and i think those are those
are
all the messages that are messages that
i can see right now
um let's see
luke says david with a straight jacket
that would be funny too
just think paula white gets paid for
that couldn't she at least have a
tambourine or maracas
us liberals built an anti-god dome
around the usa with climate change money
u.s liberals built oh my god is that
approach is that a crazy unhinged
pro-trump comment i don't even
understand that
i hope that was worth five bucks to send
it to me jeez
david do you think behind closed doors
biden will threaten trump with
investigations to make trump go away no
way
you know one of the things about joe
biden is you you can say oh i'm to the
left of joe biden and so i think biden
is just too conservative on certain
policy
fine um joe biden's just a good guy
he's just a family guy he's a guy who
suffered tremendous loss in his life
uh losing his first wife and a daughter
and then losing a son to cancer he's
just a normal good guy who relates to
people
in a normal way um i believe that
joe biden if even after all the sleepy
biden joe biden has dementia stuff
if trump calls biden and says i concede
joe biden would say
i really appreciate that mr president
and i look forward to working with your
team
like almost to a fault joe biden would
do that joe biden's just a nice normal
good guy
um and and that that's it it's not a
political assessment as a personal
assessment
he would say sir i appreciate you
calling me thank you so much it's not
that's
under that's not a policy people are
saying but but but the
but the war i'm not talking about that
i'm not talking about that let's get
updated numbers
and see if we have anything um
let's take a look here pennsylvania
still 15 000 votes we may get nothing
else today i really don't know
georgia oh georgia the georgia lead has
grown the georgia lead was only about
1800 it's now up to
42.50-ish 42-25
so the lead has grown in georgia and it
is increasingly out of reach
for donald trump based on what we're
expecting
um over 4 000 votes now there in arizona
the lead is now just shy of 40
000 votes just shy of 40 000 votes there
and then in nevada the lead is 21 000
votes nevada i believe is still updating
only once a day they are counting so
slowly there it's insane how slowly the
count
is happening in nevada but it is
happening
it is happening and that's what that's
what matters
other super chats that are coming in
joe biden called me and said sir you've
been the greatest president ever
wendy says congratulations from canada
on your new president joseph r biden jr
um is it doing more harm for news media
to not call the election
yeah kimberly this is a good point i
actually do
think that at this point the fact that
only decision desk hq has called it and
other countries have called it by the
way
uh i do think that it's giving donald
trump more cover because it it
makes it seem as though it's still
uncertain and maybe donald trump's legal
challenges are slightly more warranted
than they are
if media just called it at this point
it would make donald trump's legal
challenges seem even more ridiculous
and i do think that it is a um
uh i i believe that at this point it
should be called is the point that
i'm making uh we were told norway called
it
and uh yeah i'm not i'm not sure
who else so i do think that a network
should call it let's see what kind of a
report we're getting here
events happen here abc news president
trump meeting face to face okay
in a break there very good
all right what else did i have for you
so we did the paula white videos already
we did the big boy pants video um
i don't want to go back yeah yesterday
we got some of that video
from um what did we get from from steve
bannon talking about
beheading fauci and i guess steve bannon
has been permanently banned
from uh twitter
i believe his youtube channel has been
taken down
he deserves to be banned everywhere you
deserve to be bad but yeah uh
steve bannon suggesting that fauci and
the fbi director both be beheaded
and he's been banned a number of
different places oh and yeah
um steve bannon as many of you might
know steve bannon was recently arrested
while on a yacht and taken into custody
by authorities
his lawyer i guess is bailing on
representing him
because of his inappropriate comments we
are led to believe although i don't know
that that's actually been said
but can you believe that just insane
insane guy
um okay i want to say thanks to
a few more hold on 37.
no it doesn't make sense actually 33. oh
okay
um i do want to say thanks to the three
additional people who signed up on my
website putting us at 78
also on twitch an additional 14
putting us at 2200 and a total of 92. i
very much appreciate that
other super chats coming in they said
they were going to update in nevada
twice
a day okay yeah the last i had heard was
once a day it would make sense that they
start updating
more than that michael says i really
wish the country would amicably split
apart already
let leftists live how they wish let
rightists live how they
wish and just let it be difficult thing
to do
difficult thing to do legally but dr
chakaseki from the david pakman show
radiology department says how long
before staffers
stab ghoulius caesar in his bulbous
mango back
a two fruitis yeah i know you're kind of
joking but caitlyn collins is reporting
that
um there's a discussion happening at the
white house right now about
at what point does someone go in and
tell trump it's over
and who is it going to be and the
speculation is that it would either be
ivanka or jared kushner
it would be one of the two of them um
trump advisors at the white house say
georgia is gone
per cnn's jim acosta okay let's pull up
the acosta twitter and see
if that's what's being said but i do
want to listen to this just just to see
what is being reported now
the trump campaign meanwhile crying
election fraud saying the balloting
process is rigged against him
so what do their supporters in key
states think take a look
oh this should be great things just
don't match up
this statistician is telling us things
don't make sense draw 12 people to a
rally and his opponent draws
57 to a small town
and he wins the stage trump's never
drawn 57 000 to a rally
and overwhelmingly across the nation
communities have spoken and rejected
and rebuked an administration that has
harmed
communities all across this country
this is actually dangerous i agree with
you guys about what it means to stand
here
in the city of liberty today and say
that this
is the city that delivered the blow to
donald trump's presidency
this is our moment but it's just the
moment we got to continue
the movement and it never starts
at the top right joe biden
is not the cure
this is about harm reduction why why are
you out
they're here this election i've seen
trump signs
everywhere around arizona the rallies
have been huge
and biden gets 30 people and he wins do
you have any evidence
do you have any evidence no i'm just a
common citizen i have no evidence
what we want is a fair and safe election
listen
we're fine with losing if we lose right
you know i mean if we lose and we
haven't been cheated
we're going to handle that that's what
happened
joe biden currently leading in
pennsylvania arizona
nevada and georgia this race could not
be any tighter particularly peach state
where joe biden has a slight edge 0.1
percent
he's ahead by just over 4 000 votes
there
president trump is ahead in north
carolina what this tells us this race is
not over just yet
so what are the candidates see i'm
actually starting to wonder whether
networks are doing this
not just not to piss off trump
necessarily although who cares
i wonder if they just want to keep it
going for ratings purposes because
people have been watching news
like crazy there's nearly 300 000 people
watching this stream live
there's 200 000 people watching this
stream live
there's 70 000 people i mean okay we
have almost 70 000 people watching our
stream oh not right now but we have
um i wonder if to some degree it's
milking it milking it as much as they
possibly can i definitely wouldn't put
it past them
uh but i don't know
i don't know that's something that
people have written to me about as well
uh okay other super chats oh we were
sorry we were go we were in the middle
of going over to
jim acosta's twitter uh
okay trump advisor said giuliani
and others in inner circle are enabling
the president
as he refuses to grasp the reality that
the white house is slipping away
people are enabling him advisor said
calling situation in how
inside white house right now chaos okay
in the words of an advisor i spoke to a
short time ago pennsylvania is the fat
lady singing for donald trump
but they're having a devil of a time
behind the scenes trying to convince the
president that this is slipping away
from him
so we're actually getting that exact
same story from multiple different
reporters
uh which is which is very very
interesting deputy assistant to the
president geron smith
is leaving the white house a white house
official confirms the official said
smith was already planning to leave okay
i'm looking at the georgia thing for the
georgia thing
there's a battle over strategy right now
according to a source close to the white
house trump is telling people he wants
to take these lawsuits up until december
when the electors certify many around
trump believe it's over but trump is
digging in i'm told yeah this is exactly
what uh i i mentioned at the top of the
stream
um sources close to the white house said
some senior officials inside the white
house in the campaign
are beginning to quietly back away from
trump in acts of self-preservation
i wonder if that's literally like slowly
backing out of the oval office as trump
talks about suing people
as you can see there um in acts of
self-preservation as the returns in
pennsylvania and georgia
indicate the president will not win
re-election
um everything else is more than three
hours old okay that's pretty interesting
stuff
if that is indeed what's going on kaylee
marganani continues to just tweet
ridiculous stuff she was asking for
prayer a prayer group yesterday
um i'm probably not going to find that
tweet but
she's retweeting a lot of agit trash
uh quoting trump stuff about al qaeda i
mean it's like just
lunacy the economy grew at retweeting uh
the the econ oh no this is actually old
oh so she hasn't been tweeting that much
yeah just just uh
she did she delete the prayer call
she might have deleted it because it was
so pathetic saying who wants to do a
live prayer group tomorrow
so that's kaylee mcinanny um who else
has been tweeting from the trump team
lately
i follow a lot of these people to be
able to keep up with all the insanity
um people have been tweeting this video
a lot
who knows what brett weinstein's talking
about
we may never have to see diamond and
silk again our friend ben dixon likes
that one
uh oh this is my friend michael cusick
by the way
this is not like a well-known guy but if
you guys all went and followed michael
cusack right now
and said david pakman looked at your
tweet on stream he would absolutely love
it he's a really good guy and that would
be very funny
um what else pete buddha judge all right
so i'm not seeing any of the other big
oh hold on ronna mcdaniel okay i want to
hear what she had to say this should be
interesting
ronnie you said that uh at the beginning
that you would be laying out specific
violations and you haven't heard me yet
so i yeah
yeah i do have some specifics i was told
to hold off on sharing those but i do
have some specifics
we have the specifics we're just not
telling them to you it's like remember
the seinfeld episode
where jerry goes to rent a car and
they're like we don't have a car
and jerry says um but hold on
you don't have you lost my reservation
they're like no no we have the
reservation we just don't have the car
it's like well the car is really the key
part of making a reservation
it's a similar thing here where she's
saying oh we have specifics we're just
not going to be giving any of them to
you just be satisfied with the fact that
we have them and then that should
basically be enough
um okay all right so there we go uh the
the there are
definitely starting oh let's see what
report we have from the white house here
fraud
his defense fund is raising money trying
to get
donations to carry out these legal
challenges which can be quite expensive
and trying to give voters on the trump
side who have been with the president
over these
years uh something to hang on to whether
it materializes into a legitimate path
to pursue
some kind of uh result that would
benefit the president that's going to
play out over a period of days oh sorry
people are asking my my friend michael
it's michael cusick
k-u-s-e-k i don't know exactly i think
his twitter handle might might be like
mqsec
0-106-0 or something like that i'm not
sure joe biden has not reached 270 votes
and while there's a sense of impatience
in the country and a sense of
expectation for supporters of joe biden
we aren't there yet
according to the trump campaign and they
believe very strongly that they very
strongly play out
and so they're trying to provide reasons
and patience uh for all of the
constituencies
that are following this so closely
allison kelly uh with all that's been
going on we have not talked a whole lot
about the coronavirus but the u.s
it for the second reported in a row 120
048 americans
testing positive yesterday while
president trump waits to see if he has
won or lost he is still the president of
the united states where the coronavirus
is surging this week
what is the administration doing about
the pandemic right now
nothing well we understand that the task
force which has been led by the vice
president has not had a formal meeting
in quite some time to the incredible
pace of
i mean mike pence and the president
we're carrying out
certainly you have some of the medical
officials like
uh dr debbie burks and admiral gerard
and others the surgeon general who are
all in their positions
the department of health and human
services and secretary alex as are still
in their positions
but we've seen this shift where the
administration is very focused
on therapeutics and vaccines and wanting
to get that
through the regulatory and scientific
channels that are
required to make that more available to
americans
but we haven't seen much publicly about
president
guys they're sugarcoating what has been
a historic mishandling of coronavirus
and a weaponized ignorance campaign
um donald trump promised 100 million
vaccine doses by october 31st
uh what the report should be he promised
a hundred million doses and it's
november
that's the report that's the this load
has gone up around the country and there
are real concerns
about what it all means so there has not
been any real development
coming from the white house beyond the
cdc guidelines
and the discussion of vaccines and
therapeutics
not a lot in the way of addressing these
spikes that we have not been here
they're acting like the presidency is
functioning that's what's crazy about it
oh can you tell us uh we haven't heard a
lot about the virus from the white house
could you give us a sense of what's
going on well
you know they are uh the the task force
exists but they haven't had a meeting
they're doing nothing trump is sitting
around and people are kind of carefully
going in and starting to suggest
maybe you've lost while others are
saying let's file lawsuits and trump is
tweeting and watching tv
he's doing nothing that that's what they
they're they're acting like there's
like yes they're pretending that things
are normal and it's like oh
they've been a little bit distracted
maybe from dealing with the virus
they're doing nothing
senator harris did go to a location
downtown
in order to have one of those briefings
now in terms of his actual plan what
have we heard of course
first and foremost a mask mandate that
is something that he said he would work
with
state or local officials to try to get
to a point where there was
more standardized enforcement of mask
mandate guys
i just got a text from my friend michael
cusack whose twitter we just kind of i
happened to scroll over
and he says i was napping and my apple
watch exploded
people are following me saying they are
following me with love
that is just the best that's wild just
by chance we scrolled over
someone's uh tweet and i guess you guys
just woke him up
remember in the closing days of the
campaign when the president was talking
about potentially
firing fauci after the election that was
going to be another interesting moment
and
one we're still not at yet alison as we
wait for uh
this long election week uh potentially
to come to a close
yeah you said potentially come to a
close it just feels like the week that
might never end
mike mentally kelly o'donnell thank you
both very much
president trump narrowing the gap in
arizona but not at the rate that he
needs to capture its 11 electoral votes
yeah so let's just get the latest
numbers and just so everybody
understands what's going on
number one election already called by
decision desk
hq okay already called
over decision desk hq has called the
race
uh new york times pennsylvania at 96
percent
um joe biden up by
14 000 votes and the lead is growing
as the votes are counted north carolina
we may know nothing until next thursday
georgia joe biden is ahead and his lead
just grew in the last half hour or so
from about
15 1600 to 4 000.
arizona has already been called by the
associated press and fox news although
the new york times hasn't yet called it
they have it as a a joe biden lead of
forty thousand
thirty nine thirty nine four thirty nine
point four thousand
and uh nevada now with a biden lead of
twenty one thousand twenty
20 000 and change
originally nevada was only updating
numbers once a day
someone in the chat told me that they
are now going to be updating twice a day
so we will we're just going to continue
to all we can do is continue to watch
that for sure
okay charles says i could not legally
donate to the biden campaign from
australia so you're my surrogate i
thank you now to be clear that's a
donation to the show
it would be against the law it would be
illegal
for charles to give me in fact i think
this is
what's the name of that indian
conservative guy
what is the name of that ridiculous dude
he was he was indicted for it
what's that guy's name people tell me in
the chat i'm sure they will know
dinesh d'azuza yeah dinesh d'azuza was
doing exactly this
um so anyway thank you for the donation
to the show
i am not like you can even donate to
biden at this point i guess i mean maybe
you can i'm not really sure
uh but that's that's certainly not going
to be happening
uh let's get an update from arizona see
what's going on there
zona about 140 000 150 000 of those
are here in maricopa county now let's
look at the county here
because this morning the batch that was
released about 62 000 votes
was the best indicator that we have
received yet of where this election here
in arizona is heading
okay in that batch what we were looking
for was to see if donald trump
would win at least 59 share
of that batch let me explain this a
little bit
because if he pulled off that 59 percent
he would maintain pace
that would give him the ability to
either catch up or eclipse
joe biden right and why was this
particular batch this morning
important and informative well it's
because that batch
is going to look very similar to the
remaining 140 000 ballots
right these batches the ones this
morning as well as the ones slated to be
released tonight at 9 eastern
and then the rest of the way those were
early ballots mail ballots that were
received by folks at home
but then hand delivered on election day
at polling places
now what was the result of those ballots
that came in
they were closer to 53 percent if that
53
holds among those remaining 140 000
uh ballots here out of maricopa county
that would require
uh a heck of a performance in terms of
the ballots that are being returned
from the other counties outside of
maricopa county uh essentially
more than seven i know this guy's trying
i don't know how clearly he's explaining
what's going on
ballots and already just this afternoon
some of those counties have been
releasing numbers
and that number has been under that 75
percent so the big number we're watching
for
yeah 9 p.m eastern there's the next
batch of 60 000 okay
let me clear let me explain what this
guy is saying and i think this is the
simplest way of saying it
uh given that joe biden is ahead in
arizona
donald trump needs to be closing that
gap
by receiving significantly more of the
remaining votes than joe biden
what he is saying is based on the
numbers coming in
it would not be enough for donald trump
to close
that gap and surpass donald trump
is that fair is that like just a cleaner
explanation of what he's talking about
like he's just not cleaning he's not
closing the gap fast enough
and he's going to run out of votes
okay people like that all right i'm glad
i was able glad i was able to clarify
um okay very good so we've got that
and uh a few other things going on
okay somebody's sending me a live vote
change platform let's take a look at it
it's a github i love github
um this is from the unofficial api
powering the new york times
enable live updates we want that
and we are looking at georgia
okay so georgia six minutes ago
we had a vote different the vote
differential this is the changing vote
differential is that what it is how it's
changing over time
so it changed by 10 votes in nevada
it reduced by a couple hundred votes
north carolina very very little
reported and then pennsylvania okay yeah
this is
this is an interesting platform yeah i
like it
it's not like the best organized i would
say but it's good
um so thanks for sending that along i
appreciate that
okay people asking about
uh could this be for real
i have people telling me that the
website is down that people crashed it
trying to sign up for memberships i
refuse to believe that the website has
not crashed once other than the date
of the indian hacking incident since we
the website's working fine the website's
working fine
um i i will mention i would love it if
you grabbed a membership on my website
it's our number one funding source
and you know things are very
unpredictable in terms of
youtube and twitch and all these other
platforms for some reason we have no
idea facebook
video revenue is down 80 this month if
you ask me why i couldn't tell you
we have no contact at facebook it's this
stuff is very very unreliable many of
you remember adpocalypse from 2017.
so if you've been enjoying the coverage
i am asking you with complete peace and
love
uh grab a membership at joinpakman.com
our new coupon code this is a fresh this
is like
out of the oven fresh start all one word
all lower case
saves you seventy percent okay
try to crash my website the website is
working perfectly and i don't believe
anybody will be able to crash it because
it is it has been working extremely well
and in terms of getting to our goal
twitch subs count as well so don't
forget that
um okay jeremy says do you believe
that because there's only two parties
this 1v1
builds a you're either with me or
against me kind of vibe
of course whereas more parties give more
nuance for each voter bring the anger
that we're seeing way down yeah and i
have a lot of videos if you have not
been following my content for a while um
check my videos about how to break the
duopoly
and part of it is we need to get away
from first past the post voting
part of it is we need to change how
politics are financed i would love to
see that this is a really really big
thing it's a huge
issue and there's just a lot to it um
but you're completely right i
i want more than two parties i would
love
uh fractional representation um
with some safeguards and so on and so
forth i think this might be our friend
jacob sabarov i can't tell with the mask
let's see
yeah so we should get a updated vote
count um at
uh 7 p.m eastern time so not too long
it is jacob uh the margin has gone up
it's continued to go up for joe biden as
they've counted the votes from this
largely democratic
uh area county uh clark county where las
vegas is
first it was 8 000 margin yesterday then
12 now over 20 000.
right and we inspect another tranche of
ballots i guess
i love that word uh this evening we
don't know how many yet but we do know
there were sixty three thousand
outstanding mail-in ballots and in
addition to that there are sixty
thousand according to the registrar
provisional ballots there are additional
categories as well
ballots that need to be so-called cured
but that's a much smaller portion
cured insulted salted and cured
are people that are in line either
because they want to check
that their provisional ballot was
counted that they don't necessarily
know or understand um based on the
website
the tracker um or they want to come to
cure their ballot
they may have had an issue with a
signature that's a much smaller group
so i just want to be really clear about
that i think that um while we will
potentially see another increase in the
biden margin as these mail-in ballots
are counted
we you know just like the registrar here
we want to be slow and deliberate
to see what happens once all of the
votes come in
in totality because while i think that
margin is growing
there is still around 100 000 plus
ballots that are outstanding allison
jacob let's take a look at washoe county
uh biden is leaving jacob that's a
really tough shirt for television how
did you decide to wear a shirt that
would so throw off the camera
the ballots there are have largely been
processed okay totally honest with you
as a good advanced man uh when i was in
politics i learned to say i don't know
for sure
but it's a much much smaller number um
than here in clark county all right so
with all of this said what's the
estimate on final results from the state
what are the expectations
well they're supposed to be certified by
the 16th and if you work backwards from
there the cured ballots need to be
figured out by the 12th
the 10th is the last day that the
mail-in ballots that were properly
postmarked by the third i'd prefer the
ballots be cold smoked rather than cured
i just don't know
if i'm really you know i'm really picky
as far as that goes you should see me
when i'm choosing smoked salmon i would
like to see those ballots handled a
little bit differently
let's see what martha raddatz is telling
us and i would say
if you've noticed the number of letters
that have been
signed by former military
supporting joe biden i think that was in
the 500s
and president trump also had support as
well
in in letters from uh former military
officers
it should reflect the nature of our
country that's healthy for the military
and for the country
and martha you know we've heard a lot of
baseless allegations
frankly and kind of wild accusations
from the president
and his surrogates uh as this very
regular ordinary process of counting the
votes continue so
how do you think these allegations we've
talked a little bit about this are being
seen around the world the
impact it will have on us around the
world what do you think well
you and i know very well for having
traveled around the world how this is
probably
going over and how we know it is going
over with some allies
and particularly our allies are looking
at this is chaotic
they want a decision they've waited for
a decision
um our enemies our adversaries are also
watching
uh and they are likely delighted by this
this is exactly the kind of thing russia
wants certainly to see this sort of
chaos and that
you know will half half of the america i
don't know guys call me crazy but
you know joe biden got four million more
votes than trump and more than half the
country voted for him
should we make him president i feel like
we just should it seems
reasonable to me i i don't know maybe
i'm old-fashioned in that way but it
just seems like the guy won by four
million and and half the country voted
for him and
only 47 point something percent voted
for trump it seems very clear to me
who should be president from the people
that uh that that are left
um it's rad it's a radical idea i mean i
could potentially be a communist on the
basis of that belief yeah
all right let's check in again just with
this live election tracker i want to see
if anything else has happened
the last batch was five minutes ago
and that was from georgia
and joe biden's lead has grown by
another 24
i'm sorry 22 votes huge
breaking the differential has gone
up by 22 22
for joseph r biden jr and is that the
latest yeah
and then in the 14 minute ago update
from pennsylvania
joe biden extended his lead by five not
five thousand five five votes uh
increasing that differential wow this is
uh
this is going pretty crazy um
let's look at the trends so in georgia
trump is only averaging 31.6
of each tranche obviously he will only
fall further and further behind
with that in fact
it essentially seems impossible the
hurdle required to overcome
is showing as unknown because it just
seems impossible
in arizona trump is averaging between 56
and 58 percent
so and according to this
that's roughly what trump would need so
it is
it is conceivable it is actually
conceivable mathematically
that the the gap could be closed in
arizona which is interesting
in uh oh no alaska we're not you know
biden needs 61 percent that's not going
to happen
in nevada trump is getting only about 40
of each tranche whereas he needs closer
to 56 or even
60 so that's not looking good for him um
north carolina unlikely to go for biden
as you can see
recently biden's getting about 50 of
each
block and biden needs about 70
so as i've said i think north carolina
is done pennsylvania trump's getting
about a third of the ballot
of each tranche and he needs like 55 so
again it
doesn't seem like it's going to happen
there so this is very very important to
look at
very very important to look at because
it gives us a sense of where these are
going
all right let's see what what they're up
to now tonight joe biden narrowing in on
that magic number 270
but president trump is trying to block
that outcome in the courts his campaign
filing a number of lawsuits
let's check in with nbc news justice
correspondent pete williams and
nbc news legal contributor barbara
mcquade pete the republican party of
pennsylvania
asking the supreme court to stop the
count of mail-in ballots
received after tuesday night what can
you tell us here
right so this is about that extended
deadline between tuesday night and five
o'clock tonight
this was the deadline that was extended
by an order of the pennsylvania state
supreme court in september
the republicans have always said this is
illegitimate that only the state
legislature can change the election
rules and they've been attacking this in
court
they've asked i do think trump is
setting the the record trump is setting
this election is lawsuits filed in
response to the election
has acted on this first denying a
request from the republicans to put a
hold on that state supreme court order
and then secondly uh denying instant
review on a fast track so it's sitting
there and now
the republicans have said we want you to
issue a new order
the secretary of state earlier ordered
all the counties to keep those ballots
separate
because of the pending lawsuits over the
deadline now the republicans that want
the supreme court
so i would like to see trump actually
file a ballot for each
biden voter one ballot per biden vote
file 70 million uh
lawsuits that would be really great
check this out
alabama police officer on biden voters
put a bullet in their skull
for treason a lot of
people trump included don't seem to
understand what treason is an alabama
police captain is under investigation
after multiple complaints about a
facebook post in which he wrote that joe
biden voters should be killed for
treason
the flomation is it flomation or
phlomaton
that's a very unusual town name
flomation police officer
identified as captain scott walden made
the inflammatory comment in a thread
about people who have voted for the
former vice president over prump
according to the news station the
initial post read the idiots that voted
for biden hated trump enough to throw
the country away
thank the lying liberals and democrats
news media
walden responded by saying they need to
line every one of them and put a bullet
in their skull for treason
screenshots of the exchange were making
the rounds on facebook thursday
afternoon
as you can see here the post now is not
showing up it was either removed or
uh deleted chief charles thompson issued
a statement late thursday saying
walden's comment is under investigation
due to today's high call volume of
complaints callbacks
has callback has been extremely hard to
conduct i plan to contact all callers
soon
oh my god walden appeared to double down
on his comment where he accused people
of jumping on the gonna get them fired
train he argued he was referring not to
democrats or liberals but to people
charged with treason
well number one i don't care who you
vote for number two the comment was
about treason and what should happen to
the ones who are charged for committing
treason
no this is the dumbest response no one's
charged with committing treason
it's ridiculous uh all right i'm being
told that
donald trump has tweeted let's see what
donald trump has said three minutes ago
joe biden should not wrongfully claim
the office
of the president he didn't i could make
that claim also
you did legal proceedings are now
beginning
oh my god let me let me see if i can
understand this
uh joe biden should not wrongfully claim
the office of the president
right which he said i'm not declaring
victory
and trump says i could wrongfully claim
it also
yeah but but that's what exactly what he
did
weird i'm like confused by the tweet
okay i guess we have to i guess i'm not
going to understand it anymore what a
bizarre tweet to send it's delusional
yeah it's completely delusional
david have you seen today's youtube
video of keith olbermann citing federal
law for don jr bannon others to be
prosecuted for inciting violence no but
it makes a lot of sense to me
it makes a lot a lot of sense to me let
me say thank you to my
new website members we are now at 101
website members which is 65
more than we had putting us 65
57 putting us at 157
very special day in that we're also
including twitch subs which are at 22
27 that's another 27 putting us at 184.
very much appreciate that okay guys
let's um
let's hear from some of you guys all
right i'm gonna open up the discord
phone lines at davidpakman.com
discord i want to hear from you
please be ready to talk to me if you
want to talk to me
go into the waiting lobby waiting lobby
change your nickname okay to
location colon name location colon
name if you want to talk to me
um there's a lot of people just trying
to talk to me
uh like off air on discord i'm not
doing that right now if you want to talk
to me get into the waiting lobby
davidpakman.com
discord change your nickname to location
colon name all right let's get to uh
some of these folks
i'm very very interested in hearing
what's going on in your state
let's start with k or your country let's
start with kate from denmark kate from
denmark you're on the air
hello hello
um i've been watching the stream and
um sorry i'm a little nervous
that's okay you're doing great um
it's it's kind of wild how everybody
is protesting and
it it's kind of sorry hello
you're doing great now let me ask you
you're it's weird people are protesting
to stop counting ballots or to start
counting them or it's weird that there's
both
yeah yeah
but they're contradicting themselves
i'm curious what uh what kind of a phone
are you or what kind of a device are you
on um
my computer i don't have anything better
oh okay
no i'm just curious it's a very it's a
the the
the timber of your voice is coming
through in an interesting way
oh yeah i hope it's okay
it's it's perfect are you uh are you in
copenhagen
uh no um i'm currently
in um yeah i'm about one of the seven
communes that's
just been shut down okay i see all right
um i love denmark it's one of my
favorite places
yeah i'm happy to hear that it is weird
when like a
a just a sandwich costs 25 us dollars it
is weird it's jarring when you go from
the u.s
but it's just a great place the currency
differences
a lot yup yup yup all right good well
i'm glad that uh you're
keyed into what's going on here i
appreciate speaking with
thank you thank you all right there is
kate from denmark
very very strong opening phone call um
let's go next to uh oh hold on there was
a call from indiana that i want to get
to this is a good one let's go to molly
from
indiana molly what on earth is going on
there
uh hey david hi um
so i don't know if you've like covered
this already but
um so i was just kind of thinking about
this earlier because
i i was thinking that if trump would
have never ran for president
right and like put himself in the
spotlight yep i mean
do you think that he would be i don't
know like facing all these like criminal
um
investigations and stuff like that of
course not no no no
so much of what has uh so much of what
the trump family
is likely to experience including you
know
the complete destruction of donald
trump's brand reputation
and possible investigations for the rest
of his life and all of this stuff
um he brought it on himself i mean at
the micro level he brought on a lot of
the russia stuff himself
the tweeting the the insanity and there
is no doubt
that if the trump if trump had never run
for president he would just be quietly
continuing to make money
and get you know all sorts of different
um uh
sweetheart loans from whoever and
there is no doubt about it but you know
what that that doesn't mean we should
feel bad for him like he brought this on
himself
and he does horrible things and he
deserves to pay for it
exactly so i mean i mean when he like
loses i mean
hopefully when he loses yeah i mean do
you think that they're going to go after
him like even harder now or
i hope so i mean listen people have
asked me do i think trump will go to
prison i i don't
this is not a country that sends past
presidents to prison
and i'm not saying trump doesn't deserve
to go to prison or he does i'm not
taking a position necessarily
but this is not a country that does that
but i think there's no question
that trump could be uh tied up
in court for the rest of his life and
that that would be deserved
yeah it would be very powerful hey what
part of indiana are you in
um i'm in indianapolis oh okay i
actually flew i flew in there when i
went to northern indiana about a year
ago
indianapolis seems kind of cool i mean
it's it they you seem to have most of
the things that any
um uh you know cosmopolitan american
city has
uh oh can you still hear me
oh i'm sorry molly i accidentally i'm
sorry i accidentally muted you there
molly i'm i
am very sorry about that that's okay but
so anyway indianapolis not a bad place
to be right other than the
the the um low rankings in terms of
health education
economics and all that stuff yeah oh no
it cut out again
oh i'm here i i can hear you it's
cutting out all right molly uh i
appreciate the call
um great to hear from you okay
accidentally muted there let's go to mrs
hippie freak from hershey pennsylvania
the site
and epicenter of what's going on today
hello hershey pennsylvania
hershey pennsylvania you're on the air
hmm i guess not
let's go to zeke from missouri
zeke you're on the air
hey zeke are you there oh hello david
how are you
good how are you i'm well um my question
was do you think you know they're
talking about possible lawsuits
to trump after the presidency but also
he's threatening lawsuits
do you possibly see his appointments to
the supreme court possibly playing any
role on this do you think that there's
enough of a backlash or
or reason for them not to potentially
cater to
him having appointed two judges recently
you know my concern is if the supreme
court plays a role
it's completely plausible that it will
be a role that helps trump and hurts joe
biden
so i sure as hell hope the supreme court
does not get involved in anything
now the good news so far is that trump's
uh allegations have been so spurious
that
they're getting thrown out at a pretty
fast clip in in most cases so far i
can't say
all so hopefully it'll never get to the
supreme court
okay yeah i was curious about that uh
your view on that and that's kind of
where i was sitting with
yeah i mean let's wait and see i guess
trump has until december 14th really
which is plenty of time in theory for
something that's so urgent to get to the
supreme court
let's hope it doesn't happen yeah agreed
thank you
all right thank you great to hear from
you callers are going pretty well right
now
let's go next to maria from ohio maria
from ohio
maria from ohio you were on if you
unmute we would love to hear from you
last opportunity for maria from ohio
hello hi maria hi maria can you hear me
yes i can
maria hello yes hi hi sorry i plugged in
my microphone um
hi sorry um
i just wanted i'm a newer uh newer
newer to watching you perfect
and did you have a question today
realistic about everything
i'm sorry you're cutting in and out i
only heard the very very start of that
uh what was your question
oh boy i think maria just has a bad
connection i think that that's what i
think it's that
i think it's that simple i don't think
um i don't think anything else more
nefarious than that is going on um
okay let's go next to
you know you gotta separate the wheat
from the chaff my friends gotta separate
the wheat from the chaff
by the way if there are any trumpists
who want to talk to me
please flag yourself as a trumpist on
discord however if i go to one of you
and you're not really a trumpist then it
ends okay and we're not going to do it
again because i know people could try to
take advantage of that in order to get
on
if i if we do it and anybody's lying and
you're just trying to get on then i will
immediately shut it down
so i'm just letting you guys know about
that let's go to connor from
massachusetts
david how's it going good how are you
good uh
so my question is um with all these
lawsuits that trump is
putting forward and a lot of them being
you know quite frivolous and not having
much basis
yeah down the line do you think if it
does go to the supreme court do you
think it could be
argued that a lot of trump's lawsuits
are actually
election interference on his part it
absolutely could
and it will go nowhere and i don't
believe that that's the basis on which
they will be dismissed
yeah yeah what part of massachusetts are
you in
um the greater boston area greater
boston
wow that's good all right very good well
thank you so much for the call
thanks for taking my question my
pleasure all right let's see if we've
got any
um any trumpist
doesn't look like a single trumpist okay
i'm glad people are being i mean if
there's no trump is here that's totally
fine um
[Music]
oh wait hold on trump is oh x trump is
now that's cheating
well let's try it anyway it might be all
we it might be all we can get
uh let me go to x trumpist is it x trump
is from rhode island
uh yes hi david how are you good how are
you
good so i was a trumpos in 2016.
okay um mostly because i live in rhode
island
and my vote for that uh race didn't
really count
um but also because hillary was just
so awful in the 90s okay wait a second
you're you're telling me two different
things and neither of them makes sense
let's see if we can let's see if we can
figure
figure out let's go go one at a time
here so
your first assertion was because you
lived in rhode island and your vote
didn't matter you voted for donald trump
explain that to me well rhode island has
never gone
red yeah really yeah so
it was more of a throwaway vote i didn't
really expect him to win
um so it was more kind of a a joke vote
i guess
you could say and who was the joke on
um just more i guess myself really
that's i think that's exactly right i
think that's perfect i think you realize
you really only you it was you were
really only joking with yourself perfect
okay we're going to clip this guys
um second part was yes you voted for
trump because hillary was awful in the
90s now did it occur to you to compare
hillary in 2016 to trump in 2016 or were
you comparing hillary in 92
to trump in 2016 um it was more hillary
the whole nine whole 90s so 92 would be
part of it i guess
and why and why did you do that how did
you decide
that way to vote um honestly i don't
know
you're not sure i think it was just
still it was hillary really more for the
last 20 years so including the 2000s
and were you worried at all about the
things trump did over the last 20 years
uh yes but i didn't think when he got
into office that the
republican congress would be such um
well just be politically you know nice
about it on the air um they wouldn't
list a weak willed and have no backbone
right i don't think he'll be this bad as
far as
um kind of a third authoritarian
authoritarianism
authority yeah yeah and is it is that
authoritarianism the reason why you
flipped from trump
to biden uh yes i don't really
care for biden as far as
um i don't think he's as
liberal as i probably would have wanted
to kind of swing things the other way
wait a second let me let me back up for
a second here so hold on
so you're to biden's left biden's too
conservative for you
which means hillary's also too
conservative for you right
it's more of a it's not like a straight
left and right thing with me i'm more
like libertarianism
um like towards that end
but socially to the left of him okay
but even though you're to biden's left
you voted trump over hillary that's
very interesting very very interesting
uh yeah
and just to be totally upfront with me
are you trolling me right now or is this
for real
oh no it's for real it's for real okay
good all right listen guys
this is sociologically important i think
that this is very very interesting i
really appreciate you uh talking to us
today
yeah welcome can i just say one thing
also sure um
uh very strongly i would say that hot
dogs are
sandwiched okay um tacos
are not a sandwich they are a failed
wrap okay
um yeah that's all i had to say all
right thank you very much appreciate
that
guys i need that entire call clipped
okay i need the whole call clipped
somehow i think
twitch only allows minute clips i need
the entire call
and it is very important that i get this
entire call clipped okay
really really important um let's see
what else we've got oh trump is from
minneapolis
you are on the air
hi sorry uh can you hear me yes i can
uh i'm actually just trolling i made the
photoshop that you wanted it is in the
memes
of the discord i just want you to know
that okay all right you know what i am
going to uh
i am not going i i'll accept that
because i do want to get that um i do
want to get that meme so let me take a
look here
yeah so this is what you two minutes but
go for it this is what me walking behind
paula white yep
um let me see what's your what's your
handle i'm trying to figure this out
where
is it i put it in the i tweet it to you
and i also put it in
the hold on i think i've got it is that
one where there's a cat in it as well
no no no cat in it okay let me this i
want to bring this to you guys i think
this you'll really enjoy this
i also replied to your recent tweet with
it so i put a few places
okay uh oh i see
okay um let me see if i can put it up on
screen
and and it's where paula white kind of
has her hands out is that what's going
on
yup that is it okay there it is so there
is me joining paula white on stage for
the big prayer rally
all right cool i appreciate it i think
the next step would probably be
you know something in full motion video
where i walk by in the background
yeah maybe give give us a little more
time for that yeah yeah yeah no i
understand
enjoy your broadcast okay very good i
appreciate it uh
thanks thanks for talking to me today
all right very good um let me see so
that was trumpist minnesota which we're
done with
let me try one more trumpist this is a
trumpist i guess it says
new england trumpist does that make
sense
trumpist n e can you are you on oh hello
yeah well i'm not from nebraska not uh
new england oh okay all right what's
going on
you voted for trump uh yeah i just feel
like
i don't know biden's there's like this
whole like dark triad around him
um well hold up whoa back it up there's
a did you say a dark triad
yeah like he just i don't know he comes
up as someone who's like abusive and
like manipulative
i don't know i just don't like him wait
did you i'm hola i i we have to slow
this way down
did you say abusive yeah like have you
seen like
pictures and stuff like that you know
and like the hunter biden emails as well
wait what about hold on what about the
emails
well they just show like the big mess
kind of abusive and
uplift he likes the stonewall a lot he
did in his business deals
who did he stonewall
the the chinese with the bank accounts
and what does it mean to stonewall
well it's like this thing you do when
you're abusive when you're abusive you
stonewall
yes are you talking about gaslighting
uh no it's kind of similar but it's more
like stonewalling
stonewalling and you're not worried
about
all of the allegations against trump
including the one about
a kid right you that that those abuse
that didn't worry you
uh no because it seems like biden just
isn't respecting trump's boundaries
biden isn't respecting trump's
boundaries this is a joke right
no it's not okay if it's not
the country's in real trouble real real
real trouble i think this is a joke
why would you think that who did you
vote for for senate in
in nebraska
i did a write-in for who
um
kanye west got it thank you very much
all right guys we're done with the trump
thing because people are clearly faking
um but that wasn't bad okay please clip
that as well clip that as well for me
but let's get back to kind of more
serious things
um that one that one fell apart pretty
quickly let's go to cassidy from montana
cassie from montana i would like to hear
from you
hey david you hear me yes i can awesome
um so i i have
two things that i want to say um
so i have listings for near me around
fairfield
sorry my um i have
are you canadian originally i just heard
a sorry
um no i'm i'm i was just born in montana
and i still stay here oh um i had
i had a stroke last year oh my god i'm
29.
i'm sorry to hear that yeah but i had to
move in with my
parents yeah um and they they're
very very at least they think that
they're republican but i just
okay i am i'm i have a huge list of
things that i want to talk to them about
yeah and i have a hard time
saying things because of the stroke so
if i have something that i could really
focus on
to make a good argument
it'd be really good thing to
know i guess well listen you you're not
having trouble communicating with me so
when you say you have trouble come is it
you because of anxiety or you you have
trouble actually speaking sometimes
it's um i have to really
like talk slowly and think about
what i'm trying to say well that's good
because then you'll probably actually
say things that make a little more sense
than if you're just kind of running your
mouth
i mean listen i would try to connect
with them on one issue
and to me it seems like given your
medical situation what about the fact
that there's an entire party that's
unclear as to whether
they think it should be legal for
private insurance companies to charge
you five ten times as much because you
have a pre-existing condition
why not start there
yeah i was i was um i was
thinking of doing that i just don't know
very much about
that so i guess i have to do some more
research yeah i mean where i would go in
is go in and say listen uh now that you
don't have to say all this stuff this is
me this is me talking you know as
someone who
talks about this stuff all the time but
you go in and say listen
uh i'm not a communist i'm not a
socialist i'm fine with the market
being used to determine what cell phones
are made
and how much do we charge for cell
phones and what kitchen mixers are made
and
all that stuff but when we're talking
about people's health
understand that when you do market-based
solutions and you let
companies do whatever the hell they want
a company can say to me
because i've had a stroke you have to
pay 10 times more
than somebody who's your age but didn't
and i can't afford that so then i end up
without health insurance do you think
that's fair
mom and dad i can't imagine that they
would and
that would seem to me like the entry
point for a conversation
right yeah okay um
i uh i think i
i wanted to make a suggestion about
discord
sure um if you have a separate channel
yes and you have um like a a separate
monitor moderator in there you could
check with them if they're there you
know and be like okay we're
gonna put david you're gonna write david
in like two seconds
a call screener sort of thing yeah we're
looking we're looking into that we're
exploring a few options i like the idea
though
awesome okay and not to
take so much time um
um
the the hot dog thing yes you can kind
of make
a a a kind of a joke
question um to draw
the line between stools and chairs and
like
what is a stool what is a chair
uh um you know like a stool with a back
back on it is it like a like a a stool
or is it like an armchair i don't i
don't know i used to
um kind of make stupid hypothetical
questions like that anyhow thank you so
much listen i think you deserve a mod
ship if you want to be
this is exactly the type of um you have
upper management written all over you so
we need you as a moderator somewhere so
send me an email if you want to be a
moderator on you know twitch or
youtube or discord let me know because
that's exactly the type of high-level
thinking we need i appreciate the call
very very good um let's see
where else we want to go here it is
people are just on fire
people are on fire trying to get on
today
let's go to heather from princeton
heather from princeton you're on the air
hello hi how are you hi good how are you
i'm doing better than i was yesterday
and the day before
fair fair more results coming in um
so i have a question but i also just
wanted to say we've been watching the
show
um for years and it's crazy and amazing
to see how much is just blowing up
so congratulations thank you yeah it's
so crazy
it almost couldn't be done without bots
you know
so i was wondering especially now that
tv networks have kind of benefited from
this big extended
election news cycle right even once
coronavirus has passed do you think that
future elections are going to turn into
these sort of like
drawn out election week processes versus
election day
absolutely can you imagine anything
better for
i mean listen i'm not exempt from it
either if we just had if we had results
on tuesday night
300 000 people wouldn't be watching cbs
right now on a friday evening
and you know we wouldn't have 50 000
people across our
platforms right now either um obviously
the networks have way more power to
actually influence how it all goes down
than i do and yeah i think so this has
been just a boon for ratings
yeah not great for for mental health no
it's like watching a super long sports
game and it's just like in overtime for
days and days and you get up the next
morning and it's still going on yeah i
mean it's crazy yeah you're like
living in the nightmare but yeah
hopefully it ends well
there's people in the chat saying that
you're being overly cynical i don't
think so
yeah i mean i don't i mean at the end of
the day like news networks
they profit off of this so you know i
would think if they could draw it out in
the future then
that would make sense for them and it
also may become a normal thing because
my prediction is because the app i know
that trump claims everything was
fraudulent like
there's one side that's claiming this is
the most untrustworthy election in
history
the mail-in and early voting has gone
perfectly fine
and i can only imagine that now that
it's worked so well and people can kind
of they've got weeks where they can go
and vote or you just fill it in and you
send it
i think that there's going to be more of
this going forward of course
we'll have to see whether states just
allow right now a lot of states said you
can
vote by mail merely because there's a
virus
a lot of years you can't do that you
have to have a specific you know reason
that that's valid
but i think we're going to continue to
see more vote by mail in the future
which will make
this situation a reality now hopefully
it won't take as long
yeah i mean honestly because i'm from
new jersey so we automatically had mail
in so if you
chose to vote in person you are i
believe you're only able to vote
provisionally so your vote was counted
earlier if you
uh-oh what happened there
where where'd she go
that was weird that was princeton hold
on a second
princeton
what on earth she disappeared
oh hold on here she is hey uh okay sorry
you're back on i don't
i i actually didn't that now something
weird's going on
i didn't mute you but somehow you were
re-muted that's bizarre
oh that's weird i don't know no it's not
my connection guys people saying it's my
she somehow got muted anyway i apologize
but i think you're making absolutely
beautiful points well thank you
all right great good to hear from you
hope to hear from you again
um let's see what else we've got going
on here um we have a trumpist from japan
who wants to get on named
brandon trump is from japan
hello how are you i'm doing well um
i'm sorry about the fake uh
and i'm only moderate for trump and
recent
okay who'd you vote for in 2016.
in 2016 i voted hillary and what made
you change to trump
this year
sorry you you cut out did you say joe
biden
yes what about him i just
uh well from japan and looking at the
relationship
that donald trump had with the prime
minister over here shinzo abe
really don't have any faith that biden
is going to be able to keep up the same
kind of
healthy relationship with the prime
minister uh
suga um so my my stance is very much
of a foreign policy origin
okay so you like so when you say foreign
policy you mean
trump claimed to get along with shinzo
abe and you like that
it's not just claimed the effects over
here uh economically
and politically were easy to see
and what would it be that biden would
have done differently
that would have worsened relation or
what will biden do differently that
you're worried will worsen relationships
with japan
uh biden just doesn't have he doesn't
have asthma he doesn't have the
uh conversationalism and i understand
coming from the left perspective donald
trump has zero charisma whatsoever
but um again i am somewhat of a niche
voter trump does have some form of
leadership that people see from over
here
that um does get international policy uh
connection done and i have to say i
do respect that but donald trump's
interactions with foreign leaders are
completely delusional like donald trump
has made up conversations with shinzo
abe that never happened
donald trump's uh shinzo abe's wife at a
dinner
pretended not to speak english to have
to not speak to melania like that's a
real story that sounds to you like these
are charismatic people that are getting
along well
uh to be perfectly honest no no
but you said that's why you voted for
trump yes
oh but you don't actually believe it i
just i think necessarily that trump
very well i just think that bite will do
much work
okay and is there any other issue you
care about
is there any other issue you care about
they follow this on
minimum wage that donald trump presented
on the
uh what would be really interesting to
me sorry you're you're breaking up i
heard something about minimum wage
donald trump doesn't have the first idea
how minimum wage
even works so i but you're breaking up
your connection is really bad it must be
because you're in japan i guess i don't
know i appreciate the phone call i mean
it's certainly interesting from a
sociological standpoint to hear it but
so far a lot of the trumpists
are not making a lot of sense um let's
go next to casey from florida
oh nice yeah hi david how are you how
are you
good good doing well i hope you're doing
well yes thank you
hey first uh congratulations on all the
growth you've got you've had
thanks really nice to see um i was
knocking again but then the caller
earlier um the guy who had the stroke
and he was talking about how to
you know talk to his parents about that
that made me think about you know
something i'm thinking about with uh
the medicare talk when you talk to
republicans right um
the way i handle it that i think is
really effective
and you kind of hinted on a bit but just
to make it more clear to them
is you say you know we believe in
capitalism it works when you have
competition
right so grocery stores restaurants
there's competition capitalism works
we're not anti-capitalism
right but when you have a broken arm or
you have an emergency
there's no capital there's no
competition there because you're going
to go the nearest
doctor possible yeah well there's a
there's an economic term for what you're
talking about which is that demand is
very very
uh inelastic yeah in other words
your demand when you don't have a
medical situation
for medical services is essentially zero
no matter what the price is
your your demand for medical services
when you have an emergency
is is complete and total regardless of
what the price is and that's why we
would take
out health care services from the market
exactly and so that that vocabulary
you're just like calling it inelastic
and whatnot like that that may
make sense for someone uh who's had you
know a lot of
education they're trying and they can
turn things into abstract notions really
quickly
but when you're talking to someone who
really doesn't think about these
policies that much
you really have to talk and don't
absolutely i mean you have to i would
have to think about the right language
for someone who maybe has never studied
economics but it would be
listen uh if you have a broken arm or
appendicitis
it's an emergency and they can screw you
six ways to sunday because you need the
appendectomy and that's not fair or
something like that you know yeah and
then
and that really gets them thinking about
why it's important
exactly yep beautifully said yeah and
then the other thing about it too
um is that when you're talking to you
know trumpists or whomever
they get very defensive when you have
you put forward a good point
um and you don't have to get them to
agree right on the spot just
make your point and make it clear and
they'll think about it on their own and
then
sometimes they'll change their views
that's true that that sometimes happens
yeah
yeah i think it's it's too high of an
expectation
to get a trumpet or republican to agree
with you right away
yep fair fair point all right thank you
so much for the call i appreciate it i'm
told that the president
at least for a little while longer has
tweeted uh he said three minutes ago
i had such a big lead oh hold on you
have this is a whiny i can tell this is
whiny so we have to do it
i had such a big lead in all of these
states
late into election night only to see the
leads miraculously disappear as the days
went by
perhaps these leads will return as our
legal proceedings move
forward wow what an
whatever we don't even have to get into
it but it's it's
amazing what's going on um oh fulton
county officials hold a news conference
this virus honestly right now i probably
see what's going on here
about all of everything that we're doing
differently but if you want to talk to
me
offline i can sit down with you
and go over that
yes
are we getting any substance here
right right well it'll be uploaded
tonight that's correct
they're uploading ballots tonight
um i think there's the ballot review
committee is already meaning so i think
they
they did an upload earlier and sent they
might have sent partial results over
here
um and then the rest of them will come
tonight
because we may have full georgia numbers
tonight i think they sent something
over for them to review
can we get better mics in the room
uh i think at most times it was around
three thousand
uh that's that's probably about the
average
any other questions
i i know it was at least 900.
that then that came over the last couple
of days
the last i think two weeks all right
breaking news guys as i told you earlier
decision desk
hq has already uh oh hold on a second
guys
oh my god
we've got to start banning people this
is just ridiculous
um decision desk hq has called this race
for joe biden at 273
they say it is over we now have the
additional news that business insider
has called the race
with the same 273 electoral votes
with the headline it's over biden
defeats whoa
biden defeats trump in a nail-biting
election
to become america's next president uh
a second source it looks like they're
using that same data
the decision desk hq data a second
source has called the race for joe biden
i called it for biden also i mean listen
none of this matters in the sense that
what matters is how it gets certified
state by state and there's a wild to do
it
um but uh business insider also with the
headline it is
over joe biden projected winner oh my
god i'm using it yeah i got an ad
blocker people told me to people told me
get an ad blocker for stream
now i can't see a damn thing um anyway
it is over
and it is another one i expect that very
very soon we are going to start seeing
more calls
coming in uh pennsylvania oh let's look
at
let's look at recent vote dumps whoops
that's not it hold on a second
uh okay last vote dump let's see
15 minutes ago arizona with another vote
dump
has reduced the margin just
slightly and trump is trending
just shy of where he needs to be
to tie okay georgia
seven minutes ago the differential has
shrunk by four mild shrinkage
happening in georgia but there is no
path at this rate for donald trump
to take over in nevada seven minutes ago
the lead has grown by
520 votes 520 votes
there is not at the current rate a path
for donald trump
to take over another tranche from north
carolina
where donald trump's lead has shrunk
by about 70 votes now although joe biden
is trending short of where he needs to
be
to recover and tie um
he biden is getting more and more two
hours ago biden got 50.3 percent of the
new vote
27 minutes ago biden got 50.4 percent
and uh just eight minutes ago biden got
51.1 percent that would need to
accelerate dramatically
okay and then in pennsylvania eight
minutes ago
the lead again expanding for joseph r
biden jr
now by nearly another 400 votes
to just shy of 15 000 votes
and donald trump is a full 20 points shy
of where he needs to be to catch up
donald trump
getting about 36 percent of each tranche
now that's
for people who are joking around it's
t-r-a-n-c-h-e
okay this is the api for the data the
washington uh the new york times is
using
trump needs 56 percent and he is only
averaging
36 so the numbers are starting to come
in
and we are expecting very very soon by
that i mean sometime in the next week
uh there will be more of these calls but
indeed this has been called by decision
desk hq it's been called by business
insider
okay you know whatever but um this
continues to come in uh kamala harris
will soon be the vice president of the
united states first female vice
president of the united states
very very interesting very powerful and
as many of you know i am not an identity
politics guy but i am in favor of
recognizing
uh when there are very powerful stories
and the story of the first female
vice president of the united states um a
half-indian
half-uh jamaican um female pres
vice president of the united states
first female vp of color
i think is the way to say it very very
powerful and let's see what is happening
here in phoenix there's a
four block radius i think we're
expecting a lot of chuds here
all of this is happening right in front
of the maricopa county
election center so inside they're
counting those ballots there's 120
000 ballots that they have left to count
it's 4 30 here locally right now we're
expecting
another ballot drop right around uh
seven o'clock so we'll see how many
ballots come out but again
120 000 ballots are left to count here
over 200 000 ballots across the state
and right now we are seeing the lead
that biden has uh with the president
starting to shrink president trump
catching up he's about 30 000 uh votes
behind right now
but we should so understand it's
conceivable that biden
uh that trump will catch biden in
arizona it is mathematically conceivable
it seems mathematically inconceivable
that
uh joe biden will not win pennsylvania
and with pennsylvania arizona actually
becomes moot
is that an accurate characterization
yeah we have seen no violence here over
the last three days
and you've got a crowd it's it's mostly
trump supporters and they are mostly
angry about the way that the vote
is going uh they have got a bunch of
different complaints
sometimes conflicting complaints over
what's going on
now on the outskirts of this smaller
version of the protests that we're
seeing
we're seeing some people come in that
support biden again they're
arguing there the other thing is i'm not
sure if you can tell let's
take a walk over here just to show you
this is something that is
it's it's it's not out of the ordinary
here in arizona you see those two people
arguing
um the one with the punisher shirt he's
got he's open carrying right now so he's
got a firearm
the one with the punisher is illegal
here in arizona in fact
it's not just open carry this is one of
the most lacks uh
black states in the country when it
comes to firearms
and so we have seen some and someone's
actually yelling him this guy right here
this seems to be a building
confrontation with the armed guy
rifles and saying why are you open
carrying when here
in arizona you're allowed to carry in
your pocket so there are a lot of people
in this crowd
that have guns in their pockets because
that's illegal to do you can conceal
if you're 21 and you're not a felon here
in arizona
so they think that a lot of the the gun
wearing is performative and they don't
appreciate
courses that it brings other people
those that do have their guns
uh and there are they think it's
performance tactical rifles slung
along people they're saying that no this
is their second amendment right
and they want to wear those guns because
of the statement that it sends
because they want to make sure that they
are protected that the crowd is
protected
but again all of this is happening right
in front of the election center and
inside that election center
there is one job these people need all
these firearms for hunting this is a
perfect hunting scenario as you can see
and we're hoping to have some results a
little bit later this weekend allison
gotti thank you so much for explaining
that especially for those of us who are
here in the northeast that is not
something that you see every day so
thanks for giving us the context there
yes so we can understand what's
beautiful
one more question for you before we go i
know you are still awaiting votes
tonight
arizona is one of the states where uh-oh
what's going on now this guy's trying to
hug
uh citing voting irregularities
i'm gonna stop for a second so we can
watch these guys because it looks like
yeah
it's getting a little more heated there
so what's happening
there yeah they're actually arguing
about the six feet of social distance
you know these guys also
sometimes it also seems like they're
drunk i mean they're not behaving
normally
masks uh they're both saying hey you're
not wearing a mask the guy on the bike
is like whoa i'm not getting close to
you don't get close to me
so they're they're trying to keep that
social distance at least
right here but you can see most of the
people out here
including the man who says he supports
biden as well as
i'd say three quarters of the security
getting involved now
they're not wearing masks either so
there's a lot going on i'm sorry i
missed that question though
don't worry about it because that was
really the action that was happening and
let me tell you if anything
defines 2020 more than two guys having
an argument in the street saying please
keep your six feet of distance that's
something we never would have seen
before well you also have to
you know let's not ignore that there's a
guy with a 20-foot
trump sign despite the fact that trump
has lost this race we're just waving it
hoping to achieve what we don't know
there are voting irregularities what are
our state election officials saying
any evidence of any voting
irregularities there in phoenix
and guns yeah yeah so here in maricopa
county there has been this
issue over whether sharpie should have
been uh oh goddy schwartz holy [ __ ] that
i
i don't know if this is a safe uh
protest for jews this guy i hope is
hiding his identity
sharpies are fine in fact they were the
preferred form
uh when it comes to i think he probably
has security i think we actually saw his
security at one point
tabulators they can punch out anywhere
from 6 000 to 8 000
ballots per uh hour but
it does sound like there was some
confusion when they were giving
the instructions to people and there was
concern that there was a
bleed through on those ballots these
ballots they use here in maricopa county
and maricopa county we're just talking
about maricopa county we can't batch for
any other counties
but they aren't lined up perfectly they
are offset on purpose so that if you
fill out
a sharpie on the other side it doesn't
line up
you can't have that accidental bleed
through that might select something else
on the other side
so they're saying that it's fine but
we've got democrats and republicans
both saying that uh they're a little bit
concerned about the instructions that
were given
they've both taken it to court and now
it's in the what a mess it's probably
gonna go uh in front of a judge and we
could have a decision there
all right gotti schwartz thank you so
much this was by far the most animated
live show
look at this evening a whole lot going
on there in maricopa
thank you so much just shoot what's
going on there i just want to see what's
going on with these guys
wow october jobs are poured out today
i'm not thrilled that they cut it i
wanted to stay there and see there
there was some zombie action there all
right let's see i'm oops i'm just going
to close this so i don't keep
accidentally going to it
i'm told that there are there is more
been more data that came in
um okay arizona
exact oh that's interesting another bun
oh wait zero that's this doesn't make
sense votes remaining oh
they they just found more votes in
arizona look at that
so arizona was down to 212 votes
remaining
they've now found more votes which means
that the percentage trump needs has gone
down
okay so that's that and then
uh i guess that's all i'm seeing at this
point in time
okay so so things getting very very wild
there
in arizona a lot of uh
extremely oh sometimes you have to
reload let me just reload then
i just want to be sure i have the latest
stuff
two days ago nine minutes 16 16 16. okay
yeah no we didn't we didn't miss
anything there
okay so um we have already seen decision
desk hq and business insider call the
race it's not completely clear why
others have not called it
um we are at 141 new members which is
plus 40 from where we were
that puts us at 224 we're also at 22
38 on twitch which is another 11 at 2
35.
all right guys that's going to do it for
me we're going to continue monitoring
the vote i'm really glad you joined me
please break the subscribe button if
you're watching on youtube hit the
subscribe button we've been adding
10 000 youtube subscribers a day if you
can imagine that
it's unbelievable unbelievable ten
thousand a day
hit that subs and i'm sorry by found i'm
sorry not found votes
they've they've received more they've
tallied more votes i'm sorry that's the
term trump is using and it's a terrible
term votes votes were
um uh identified as
yet uncounted thank you make sure you're
following me on twitch
make sure you like the the page on uh
facebook
and of course subscribe on youtube we'll
be monitoring and hopefully
more official calls coming in the next
hour or two